or they ran away from him as fast as
they could this is 20 years ago now we
see racist tropes emanating from the
White House itself and we see others
welcomed at the White House or
encouraged by the president and this has
got to stop and I know there's some
folks out there who say you know look I
don't like all that stuff but I'm just
in it for the economic policy now I
think the economic policy is terrible
too but we just have to ask at what
point can you accept this kind of racism
at what point does looking past it
itself become complicity and I would say
it's complicity from the get-go so then
I'm curious sorry to jump in whether and
how racism comes up from white folks on
the campaign trail when you're out
talking to people I think a lot of us in
this room probably saw that video that
went viral in which after a police
involved shooting you know a man stood
up and said if African American people
just stopped committing crimes
essentially we would be fine right so we
know that instance does it come up out
of the awareness of racism that that
I've developed through the campaign has
come from conversations with kids like I
got to come we went to this incubator in
LA co-founded by Nipsey Hussle whose
remarkable what's going on there they
got they got entrepreneurs do exactly
the kind of thing that we're hoping to
promote in the Douglass plan which is
why I was there I wanted to kick around
some of these idea yes and there
happened to be a group of young people
from mostly the Midwest they were young
mostly black kids and kids of color who
really good coding stem that kind of
thing so somebody had arranged for them
to come to the west and see these tech
companies really cool and um you know
because I'm a presidential candidate
because they were there they arranged me
to talk to these kids kind of on the fly
and
[Music]
the first question comes from this kid
who's actually from Indiana 14 years old
and he says he knows a lot of racial
tension in it and in my school what do
you think we can do about it
and I want to make sure I understood
what he was saying so I asked him what
what he meant and he described being
called racial slurs in school I'm
thinking this isn't that's not rape so
tension right that's abuse and I think
there are a lot of people in polite
circles in in the progressive white
world who think and frankly at one point
earlier in my life I did too
that that was just how much we were up
against and between the that and the
more coded subtle systemic thing if we
don't tackle this in my lifetime I am
convinced that it stands to unravelled
in American project perhaps in my
lifetime as mayor of South Bend and you
alluded to this earlier you you've had a
bit of a complicated relationship with
the app in American community there was
the police chief that you hired as mayor
there was the shooting of The Heretic
Logan just a couple of months ago by a
white police officer nope
who's in vents specifically those two
events how did they or have they changed
how you view race racial dynamics in
this country racism
of course I have them and this is the
thing about being a mayor of any
communities you hold inside you
everything that is in that community and
so when the community is divided that
happens inside you too in my first year
here we had a terrible situation where I
removed a police chief is that I made
and that I was explaining myself to the
community and we're really missing the
point for why so many in the community
felt like they could not trust either
the police or my administration after
what happened there and it's because
this isn't just about one case this
isn't just about one person this is
about the entire relationship of black
residents to law enforcement and by
extension their relationship to
structures of power across our country
now you fast forward to this year eight
years later where we've been through a
lot as a community and where I was able
to earn and keep a lot of support from
the black community even though they
might folks might agree with me unwanted
if she would disagree on another issue
but broadly had had that support but we
had as you mentioned a police involved
shooting still being investigated I
called for an outside investigation and
that's what's happening right now and
even as we wait for details we don't
have to wait to know that what's at
stake here is whether people can look at
a police officer and feel safety rather
than feel fear and that goes beyond any
individual case and it goes beyond any
individual policy and what I and I think
a lot of mayor urban mayor's are
thinking about is how can we do as much
as we can at home and again
conversations not just specialty
conversations for audiences of color but
national conversation and action plan on
what we're gonna do so that we can
finally be the generation that saw these
inequities wrestled down the side really
quickly as a follow up with regards to
the police chief if you could do it all
over again would you still have fire yes
when somebody I've appointed when I have
to find out from somebody else that
they're being investigated by the FBI it
changes my ability to to trust them and
as a public safety adviser but I mean to
be cute about it because it was really
tough there's several things I wanted
would have done differently first of all
I would have sat down we had a
complicated and awkward phone
conversation I would've just sat down
and explained why did after that I never
again fired somebody who reported
directly to me without a conversation in
person I would have better understood
why the community was not interested in
what I had to say about the finer points
of the federal wiretap Act because this
wasn't what what read to me is act anger
and some of this may be a cultural thing
too it is a cultural thing some of what
read to me is anger and just as a human
being especially a 29 year old mayor in
my first few months people I would call
if I'm in danger the people I don't feel
safe
if around and I came to understand that
slowly and the hard way but I came to
understand that as mayor how do you
respond to criticism of your own
response from the black community to sue
the latest officer-involved shooting
back home and given the strenuous
obligations of the offices of president
presidency to respond the situations
like Ferguson are there lessons that
you've learned that you would apply them
yeah very much and look nobody will be
he not everybody will agree on our
response but our response has included
drawing the community into a process to
learn about it and shape and reform if
necessary everything from how we do body
cameras which we introduced last year
but did not serve us what well this time
because they were an act and again this
may be just a matter of of Kult but but
this is about ultimately as about result
it's about what we can do to make people
safer and and of course our response to
this as a community is on I'm going what
a president has to do is not just
implement good policies but called
people to their higher values and
especially in a post Ferguson
environment we need to have a president
who is capable of letting different
parts of the country know that this is
not a zero-sum game that for example
there is nothing anti law about
demanding racial justice it's just that
the law has to actually be just or be
applied than adjust fashion we should
live in a world where being emphatic
Aleppo minority and emphatically Pro
police would never come into tension
would never be things that would that
would run against each other but we know
that it's not reading that way right now
and this can't just be fixed by a mayor
or by a president I'm not here to say
say that I became mayor and we solved
racism or discrimination or poverty or
violence in our city
what I'm here to say is that it matters
playing the instruments the president's
conducting and calling the tune and you
need to have a president who has some
sense of what's at stake and for those
experiences that the president can't
know by lived-experience right I don't
know what it is to be a woman I don't
know what it is to be black but but I am
committed to empowering those who can
bring that to the table and I've learned
the hard way what happens when people
don't feel included or empowered mayor
Pete thank you so much two minutes you
have two minutes to make some okay first
of all I appreciate the chance to
explore some of the toughest issues
facing our country in our cities in a
very honest way and again this is what
the best journalists do I'm not working
the reps here I'm just say this is what
I value about what's happening right now
especially in this critical moment where
our country is at what I am convinced is
a fork in the road that will determine
whether the rest of this century goes
well or goes poorly for the United
States of America that we need to have
the kind of critical attention and
serious inquiry that journalists and
journalists of color are uniquely able
to provide that what is at stake in this
presidential election is in my view what
unbelievably ugly as it is proving to be
right now and this is why I am running
at a moment when this is needless to say
a non-obvious career move for a
Midwestern mayor in his 30s but I also
know why this is the only moment in the
history of the Republic
look when somebody like me doing
something like this would get as far as
we've gotten it's an awareness that we
can't recycle the same in arguments the
same ideas often the same faces that
have dominated Washington for literally
as long as I've been alive
that we need to break through with
something different this is not about
making America great again because there
is no honest politics that revolves
around the word again this is about
deciding how to make the future better
than the past and because the very lives
of my generation depend on it and
because of everything I have learned
through the good the bad and the ugly of
guiding a low-income diversity through a
transformation in our trajectory I am
prepared to do it and that's why I'm
running for president thanks